Oppenheimer is one of director
Christopher Nolan's more straightforward
films but even this historical biopic
takes some dramatic license and makes
some choices that may have film goers
scratching their heads
Nolan is no stranger to depicting time
in unique ways and Oppenheimer is a
great example of that the film is told
through two distinct timelines one
focused on oppenheimer's Rise and
another looking at Louis strauss's
attempts to tear his rifle down to
distinguish the two Nolan depicts
oppenheimer's view in color while
strauss's is in black and white this
could be to make it clearer to audiences
that these storylines aren't happening
at the same time but it feels like Nolan
is attempting to do something more with
this what he's trying to accomplish is
so unclear though that Nolan had to
explain it before the film even released
Nolan talked with the Associated Press
about the significance of using black
and white to denote perspective saying I
knew that I had two timelines that we
were running in the film one is in color
and that's oppenheimer's subjective
experience then the other is a black and
white timeline it's a more objective
view of his story from a different
character's point of view while this
explanation does clear up what Nolan was
going for that concept of subjective
versus objective doesn't necessarily
come through in the film ultimately the
choice makes things a little murky both
thematically and in terms of
Storytelling
throughout Oppenheimer the title
character has small visions that
somewhat foreshadow his eventual rise in
quantum physics as well as his creation
of the atomic bomb from Stars spread
across rooms that Oppenheimer is in to
the rings of a nuclear model moving in
front of him Nolan uses some
mind-bending visuals backed by some
incredibly thrilling sound design
Oppenheimer sees things in sort of
different dimensions while these moments
add to the visually stunning nature of
the film The visions do make things a
tad confusing since what they are is
never really explained are they simply
meant to foreshadow oppenheimer's future
is it a look into oppenheimer's mental
state or are they tied to a greater
force in the universe at one point a
scientist character mentions that some
people are capable of seeing the quantum
realm where subatomic particles are
visible so maybe these scenes are meant
to hint at oppenheimer's growing
connection to the subatomic world with
which he would eventually interact if
that is the case it's something that
kind of breaks the more realistic tone
throughout the rest of the film the
visual in these sequences are really
cool but they also may leave some
audience members wondering what they
were all about
the film sees Oppenheimer bring together
the most talented and knowledgeable
physicists he can find so it's no
surprise that they constantly use
scientific jargon you know Isotopes and
you know explosives you can't tell us
what you're doing in most of the team's
discussions scientific terms get thrown
around with regularity as they make new
discoveries and start new tests even for
viewers who don't know quantum physics
all that well the group flexing their
knowledge adds some fascinating Intrigue
to the scenes and even raises the stakes
in certain moments that said their
constant use of science jargon doesn't
help viewers who haven't taken some
high-level science classes even remotely
understand what they are talking about
instead of explaining what some of these
terms mean or breaking down the concepts
on display the characters freely talk as
if General audiences have any idea what
they're discussing although these
conversations are likely meant to Simply
immerse viewers in the moment and the
perspectives of the characters it is
likely to make some viewers feel lost
there are moments where you almost want
to raise your hand and ask questions
because these characters are talking
about Concepts that are totally going
over everyone's head
when Oppenheimer first arrives at
Berkeley he looks to create more
interest among the student body in
quantum physics but he's only able to
get one student to initially join his
class eventually oppenheimer's class
begins to grow and he's even able to
amass such a strong enough following
that scientific and political
discussions begin blossoming around
campus that makes for a compelling story
about oppenheimer's burgeoning influence
but it's hard to believe that only one
student would be inclined to attend his
class or that the class would be allowed
to continue with a roster of just one by
the time Oppenheimer is at Berkeley he's
already started to make a name for
himself in the science community so his
presence would surely get more people to
come to his class out of sheer curiosity
sure quantum physics wasn't necessarily
a popular subject at the time but with a
rising Talent like Oppenheimer in front
of the class it seems like more people
definitely would have shown up on the
first day and again why would Berkeley
let the class continue with just one
student the dramatic effect is there but
think about it too long and questions
begin to pop up Oppenheimer first meets
Gene tatlock at a party and it's
instantly clear that they have an
attraction and maybe some sort of faded
connection but their relationship never
really forms into anything meaningful
and to be honest it's a perplexing part
of oppenheimer's story the film doesn't
necessarily do a great job adding depth
or meaning to oppenheimer's romantic
relationships and his Dynamic with Gene
is mostly just confusing why is he so
drawn to her when she just constantly
pushes him away and throws his flowers
in the garbage it's mostly just a
physical relationship and they rarely
show any signs of being anything more
than hookup Buddies the film tries to
characterize their relationship as
something more but never provides the
context or insight to make viewers feel
like there's something else there by the
time Oppenheimer and Gene really show
any real emotion towards each other it's
too late and this storyline is cut short
it's barely even brought up in the
film's second half the relationship ends
up as a plot thread that's left hanging
and unclear as Oppenheimer begins work
on his secret project there is a lot of
stress in his household one night
Oppenheimer returns home to the sounds
of his child crying his wife Kitty is
worn out from doing all the child care
by herself instead of being a good
father and trying to resolve the
situation himself Oppenheimer opts
instead to abandon his kid for a while
by taking him to chevalier's so that he
can take care of the baby it's a pretty
unheroic moment for the film's Title
Character to say the least maybe the
story beat is meant to show
oppenheimer's Growing obsession with the
project or a hint that his two lives are
growing even further apart it's still a
bizarre moment and it's even weirder
that Chevalier and kitty never bring it
up again nor does anyone else it's not
surprising to see Oppenheimer be a
little cold or uncaring towards his
family since that's kind of who he's
shown to be at times but his choice
stretches that idea a little too far
without delivering any meaningful
ramifications
as the big test for the bomb Oppenheimer
and his team are crafting nears there's
some reasonable concern that the US
government could cause harm to civilians
with it you're the man who gave them the
power to destroy themselves later when
the government uses the bomb on the
Japanese cities of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki to end World War II in the
Pacific Oppenheimer understandably
starts to feel guilt and maybe even has
some regrets about his creation however
his belief that the bomb was going to be
solely used on the Germans was very
faulty it kind of doesn't make sense
when he claims to think that he didn't
know what the government was going to do
at the bomb after Germany surrendered
maybe oppenheimer's denial that the bomb
would be used is just a way for him not
to feel responsible for what happened
and still feel proud of his creation but
it seems like he's smarter than that and
that he'd have some sort of awareness
that if he and his team made the bomb
it'd be used at some point his whole we
don't make the choice on how the bomb
gets used mentality just feels like an
excuse to not feel responsible for the
deaths of thousands it it's likely that
the book the film is based on American
Prometheus the Triumph and tragedy of J
Robert Oppenheimer digs further into
these mental gymnastics but the film's
depiction ultimately feels like an
incredibly smart man playing dumb to
avoid feeling bad
oppenheimer's relationship with Kitty is
equally as bizarre as his relationship
with Gene since there's such little
emotional connection between them that
viewers are left wondering why they stay
together their relationship is barely
shown in the film and by the end it
feels like there are more reasons for
them to break up than to stay together
after all Oppenheimer has multiple
Affairs during their marriage isn't
really around to help the family out and
even uproots his family to the testing
site they barely look like they're in
love throughout the film so it's kind of
strange how kitty just stays and even
defends Oppenheimer later on maybe she's
just forced to stay with him for
security reasons since she could likely
know what's going on with the bomb but
that seems a little lofty also it's not
like she hasn't left a relationship
before since she got divorced so that
they could be together and she even
stated that she wasn't exactly thrilled
to be a housewife when they first got
together Kitty has all the reasons and
history to leave Oppenheimer but never
does which is one of the most confusing
parts of the entire film
throughout all the black and white
scenes it's clear that Strauss is
desperately trying to tarnish
oppenheimer's reputation and make him
seem dangerous to the US government it's
eventually made clear that he's
concocted quite a Revenge plan to take
his former rival down for good but it
just seems so needlessly complicated
from him having to appear publicly to
dispute Oppenheimer to the back room
trial there are just so many moving
pieces and players involved that it's
tough to believe that stress pulled this
all together without anyone noticing
government secrets leak all the time and
despite there being security clearance
needed for almost everything surely
someone was going to spoil strauss's fun
with his plan being so elaborate it's
kind of no wonder that it all fell apart
in the end and backfired on him Strauss
attempts to show himself to be a
mastermind like his rival but ends up
with egg on his face it's not surprising
since he overly complicated plan never
really seems possible or easy to follow
in the first place
after oppenheimer's atom bomb devastates
Hiroshima and Nagasaki he feels
responsible for the Carnage and reveals
to President Truman that he has blood on
his hands his martyrdom and the later
parts of the film May reflect his desire
for forgiveness however if he felt so
bad about what happened why does he
continue to consult and work on future
Atomic projects why doesn't he just quit
surely others might have followed in his
footsteps or the government would have
had to bend a little bit to keep him
around since Oppenheimer was a widely
recognized Name by this point and a
crucial part of the Project's success
instead he just decides to continue his
work even though he knows it could be
used for destructive and deadly purposes
oppenheimer's sense of guilt is
certainly a flimsy part of his character
maybe he felt that he had to stay on so
he could keep tabs on these projects so
nothing worse Could Happen history
offers insight into these questions but
within the confines of the film
oppenheimer's continuing work on the U.S
Atomic project is a very confusing
aspect of his character